battleground states have become literal
battlegrounds especially in kenosha
wisconsin
take a listen to what's going on on the
street there
[Music]
uh
those are real gunshots they've been
going on now for days
in kenosha wisconsin ostensibly prompted
by
an officer-involved shooting not an
officer-involved killing
really though this isn't about that
specific incident
that isn't about any other particular
incidents this is about
the 2020 election the theorist
klaus switz famously said that war is
the continuation of politics
by other means well it looks like we're
pretty deep into
other means territory we will examine
what it means for the election
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from sergeant
buck
joe biden says vote for me i'll be a
nice guy
donald trump says vote for me i have a
to-do list
yes that's true that's a good way to put
the difference in this
election you've got donald donald trump
saying look here's my agenda
here's what i've done so far what have
you got to lose
you might not like my personality but
i'm going to do all these good things
and joe biden just says look i'm a nice
guy you remember me
remember the good old days we'll restore
the soul of this nation
by continuing to kill a million babies a
year making taxpayers pay for it i don't
know
it's just all this feel-good vague
nonsense because they have no
affirmative agenda at least not one
that's particularly popular
and you can see that reflected in some
of the numbers which we will get to
but i think there is an aspect of the
the political violence that we're seeing
around us that that people
haven't really reported on people
haven't really acknowledged this
ostensibly for the past what three four
months more than that even
this has been an anti-police protest
and and then riot and then you know
madness all around the country
because the police are racist and
they're gunning down innocent people
all over the country now we know that
the premise of that is not true
but what about even the claim this is an
anti-police protest
there was a a guy a reporter goes out
into the field
and he's covering seeing how
everything's going he gets a gun pulled
on him
he gets a gun pulled on him by some
marauding rioter
who who just pulls it out of his pocket
points at his head and then keeps
walking the guy keeps walking right
this is not how politics is supposed to
work is this an anti-journalist protest
no but i don't think it's an anti-police
protest either
most especially because there is a guy
who
i guess one of the demonstrators or
writers who knows
who ended up getting shot in the head
i'm not going to play the clip
itself just take a listen
to the first thing that they call for
the minute
that this guy gets shot
get a light on it get away put pressure
on it
where dude where where's the hole wait
where are you here in his
call the cops call the police at the
anti-police protest
i didn't want to play the clip itself
because it's kind of gory to watch a guy
get shot in the head i don't think
there's any reason to do that
but what you just heard is pretty
important
because what it shows you is that there
is a fantasy element to everything
that's going on and
even the demonstrators know it even the
people are going out saying this is
about
anti-police the minute that real bullets
start flying
what do they say call the cops call the
police please we're done playing we're
done pretending
i'm sorry it's as though they had woken
up out of some kind of a fog
right that that raises a question
what is this really about i don't think
it's about anti-cop
i don't think it's about race i don't
think it's about
any of that stuff i think it's all about
the election i think you are seeing
political violence in the run-up to a
major presidential election
because the left has had trump
derangement syndrome now for more than
four years
and they were not going they didn't
intend to allow the election to turn out
that way in 2016
and they sure don't intend to let the
2020 election
keep president trump in power they will
do
anything in their in in their power to
lie to cheat to steal even if it causes
violence even if people are dropping
like flies over there
in wisconsin is it any coincidence that
this is happening in wisconsin
i don't think so i don't think it's just
some random coincidence
that the battleground state remember the
state that made the difference
in the 2016 election happens to be right
now
where all this violence is taking place
there's a lot of evidence though that
this that this violence
does not need to take place that this is
not this is not being spurred by
grassroots events
it is being encouraged by people who at
the top of the democratic party
are increasingly desperate and
hysterical to hang on to power now even
threatening not to concede the election
we will get to more of that evidence but
first i got to thank our friends
over at liquid iv very important
to stay hydrated with the la heatwave
you know
the the great friends over there at
liquid iv
may not be able to put out the wildfires
but liquid iv will quench your thirst
and hydration
needs liquid iv just launched their
newest line the energy multiplier
this thing is absolutely fantastic with
roughly 100 milligrams of clean caffeine
it is the perfect coffee replacement and
an all-natural alternative
to processed energy drinks for a
sustained energy boost
throughout the day think the thing i
love about these guys i get a little
nervous about
the energy drinks you buy at the at the
gas station for instance you know
i don't know about all that stuff liquid
iv though it's so simple it's got
cellular transport technology
delivers the optimal ratio of nutrients
for more
efficient uptake it's great i like it
some people like it after
they've gone and done a little athletic
activity you know that i don't do a
whole lot of that
but after a couple coca-colas with the
boys out it also makes the next morning
pretty bearable liquid iv is available
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com
and use code knowles use called michael
rather not knowles
you have to use the other half of my
name at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code michael mich ael
liquidive.com start fueling your
adventures today
at liquidive.com promo code michael mich
ael so obviously it's very difficult
when the bullets are ringing out people
are dropping like flies to defend
the rioting but cnn is going to take on
the challenge so cnn
on wolff blitzer's program they've got
the headline america
in crisis and and they point out an
honest chiron
underneath they say 8 p.m curfew ordered
after violent protests over police
shooting
of unarmed black man in wisconsin so
it's already still
quite a provocative chiron now take a
listen to what happens
as the segment progresses first let's go
to cnn's omar jimenez he's in kenosha
for us omar this incident was captured
on video we want to warn our viewers uh
the video is graphic very hard to watch
but set the scene for us
walk us through what you're learning
that's right wolf well there are a lot
of investigations playing out right now
led up to jacob blake being shot but
what we do know for sure
is that people are angry they have
expressed that anger
there it is 8 p.m curfew ordered after
protests
over police shooting of unarmed black
man in wisconsin
what happened to the violent violent is
gone no more violent
i guess the protests magically got more
peaceful
in between that because some editor over
there at cnn
decided nope we cannot permit this to go
up there it's a little too honest
so you've got the mainstream media
coordinating with elected democrats and
most importantly
the democratic activists the terror arm
of the democratic
party blm and antifa on the ground who
are ginning up this violence and now
causing people
to be shot how pervasive
is that power of the mainstream media
well the republicans
have the answer to that and i got to
give them credit
these party conventions are not great tv
they usually are pretty tone-deaf about
what's going on in the country
but they made one really excellent pick
at the republican national convention
they chose to have the covington kid
come out and speak
not some polished politician not some
activist whose name we've known forever
it's that kid who was wearing the maga
hat at the national mall
he was right in front of the lincoln
memorial and he
he was just standing there a pro-life
rally this crazy native american man
comes up starts banging a drum in his
face
a group of black supremacists called the
hebrew israelites were shouting all
sorts of terrible names
and the mainstream media decided to try
to ruin this kid's reputation
destroy his life pounce on him all of
the above
now actually this kid sued cnn he sued
the washington post he sued other news
organizations
so far cnn and washington post have
settled because they knew that he was in
the right
so the rnc gets nick sandman to start
speaking
in front of the lincoln memorial where
it all started on the power
and the corruption of the mainstream
media
well the media portrayed me as an
aggressor with a relentless
smirk on my face in reality the video
confirms i was standing with my hands
behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that had
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum in my
face
and two i was trying to follow a family
friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family
your school or your community before i
knew what was happening it was over
one of mr phillips fellow agitators
yelled out
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa what i thought was a
strange encounter
quickly developed into a major news
story complete with video footage
my life changed forever in that one
moment
the full war machine of the mainstream
media revved up into attack mode
they did so without researching the full
video of the incident
without ever investigating mr phillips
motives
or without ever asking me for my side of
the story
and do you know why because the truth
was not important because the truth was
not important this is something we've
been saying on this show now for
well for a very long time but in recent
memory over the past few days
which is it's not that the mainstream
media
intentionally lie all the time it's not
that the mainstream media
want to invert the truth all the time
though sometimes they do
it's that the mainstream media don't
care about the truth
they don't care the truth is completely
irrelevant
to what the mainstream media do it's not
that they're
constant liars it's that they're cynics
they think
the truth doesn't matter they are there
to propagandize for the democratic party
and so
are the protests violent or not violent
doesn't matter move the chiron around
who cares
what makes us look good which is the
best way to position
us whoops sorry we left that word
violent in there can't do that
that's what nick sandman saw and he goes
on to make a pretty interesting point
there
he says that what we've been seeing all
around the country
is a media that is pushing
anti-trump anti-conservative
and anti-christian narratives don't
forget this is a catholic high school
student
who was attacked because he was at the
march for life there is a bit of a
christian element here too
and i think this was so brilliant i mean
i think this guy has a lot of political
clarity and vision here
which is all of these issues that we're
talking about are not just the surface
level issues
they go down much deeper to use the
specific example of wisconsin
this is not just about the shooting of
some black man who had a warrant out for
his arrest for sexual assault
and domestic abuse who's reaching into a
truck it's not just about that
why was it in wisconsin why is it
happening right now why is this being
popularized by the media
because it has a political angle to it
because the democrats and the left
believe that this will help them
win the election same thing with the
mail-in ballots why is the left suddenly
the great champion of the post office
and and trying to get everybody to mail
in their
votes the the cdc dr fauci all these
people say we can vote in person
so why are the democrats trying to keep
people from voting in person
don't the democrats want people to vote
no the democrats just want people's
votes
so the easiest way they can collect
people's votes is by having them stay
home
mail them in and then they can implement
their corrupt
voter fraud schemes that they've
implemented many other times in many
other places around the country
including recently in new jersey
it goes down a little bit of a level
deeper you've got to see through the
news and what sandman is seeing is
it doesn't just stop at the political
level it has a cultural level too and
ultimately it has a religious quality
because as henry edward cardinal manning
one of our favorite guys to quote on
this show is he says
at bottom all human conflict is
ultimately
theological and that's what we're
talking about different visions
of the world different visions of life
different visions of work
different visions of what our purpose is
here actually that that
youtube question that we mentioned from
yesterday at the top of the show is
pretty apt here and it's apt for how the
republican party
is looking at the election you've got
donald trump saying here's a list of
things i'm going to do
and then you've got joe biden saying i'm
a nice guy and the other one
is a mean guy so vote for the nice guy
but this has
important implications specifically for
race which we will get to in one second
first though
i got to thank our friends over at
readywise now is a better time than ever
to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food
options ready wise has many options
they've got emergency meals
free dries freed freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables
for convenient on-the-go nutrition and
new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities now
of course me i'm not exactly the most
outdoorsy type in the world
so it's not that i'm i'm most interested
in the adventure meals i know a lot of
people are
but life is an adventure these days
folks and you've got to be prepared
especially
as you look around at some of the
situations in this country
ready wise the thing i love about them
first of all they're very good
they're very high quality i kid you not
we got we had some samples over at the
office
and we had a producer who would he would
take the samples i said
it's not the apocalypse yet is it we're
not in an emergency you don't need to
eat that
he said i want to eat it because it
tastes very good and it did it does
it continues to taste very good you
should stock up now
you'll just have peace of mind and
you'll have a very excellent product too
that you can look forward to if the time
does come when you will need it this
week
my listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com when entering knowles k
wlas at checkout or by calling
855-453-2945
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy there is no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that is
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com
promo code knows to get free shipping
think about on this question of race
the question that the democrats ask
they ask specifically are you racist
are you anti-racist is your friend a
racist is he
or she a racist it's all about
a state of being it's all about are you
this
or are you that republicans and
conservatives don't ask that question
we ask the question have you been unjust
to somebody on the basis
of his race have you done a thing
that would be bigoted or racist or
unjust or whatever
whatever word you want to use we talk
about discrete actions why because
if you look at discrete actions you can
tell that america is not a racist
country or an evil country or an unjust
country or whatever
you can see that it's so obvious but if
you ask the vague question
are we racist we're the founding fathers
racist what does that question even mean
that's not even a meaningful question
you have to get into the specifics
the left doesn't like the specifics but
on this question of race which the rnc
decided they had to address
they had an eloquent spokesperson on
racial issues he would be the only
black republican senator tim scott
he comes out and he had a line for the
ages i think people are going to
remember this one
he pointed out that within the span of
just
one lifetime his family went from cotton
to congress my grandfather's 99th
birthday
would have been tomorrow growing up he
had to cross the street
if a white person was coming he suffered
the indignity
of being forced out of school as a third
grader
to pick cotton and he never learned to
read
or write yet he lived long enough
to see his grandson become the first
african-american
to be elected to both the united states
house
and the united states senate in the
history of this country
our family went from cotton to
congress in one lifetime
cotton to congress in one lifetime
that's a good line
that's a good line and on this racial
issue which
the democrats have put forward and the
republicans feel the need to answer
i mean i guess the the strongest move
would have been if the republicans
didn't even feel the need
to address these particularly racial
questions because we could just reject
the premise outright
but assuming that we're not going to do
that i thought
senator scott did such an excellent job
here of
of showing that difference between ask
are you racist are you not racist and
showing
the tangible reality what is possible
if a guy can go from cotton to congress
in one lifetime america's not a racist
country
if a guy named barack hussein obama
who who is black before there were any
black presidents if he can be elected
president this is not a racist country
america might have a lot of other
problems if you're electing barack obama
but
racism isn't one of them and
the republicans had another one of their
politicians come out and
address this racial question in it was
from a slightly different angle but i
think it's important
particularly in light of what's going on
in wisconsin
he was addressing joe biden's comments
where joe biden said if you don't if you
don't vote for me then you ain't black
if you don't know that you're
going to vote for the biden campaign for
other democrats then you ain't black
the first black attorney general of
kentucky
did not particularly care for mr biden's
comments
the question is will we choose the path
that gives us the best chance
to meet those universal desires or will
we go backward
to a time when people were treated like
political commodities
who can't be trusted to think for
themselves
i think often about my ancestors who
struggled for freedom
and as i think of those giants and their
broad shoulders
i also think about joe biden who says
if you aren't voting for me you ain't
black
who argued that republicans would put us
back in chains
who says there is no diversity of
thought in the black community
mr vice president look at me i am black
we are not all the same sir i am not in
chains
my mind is my own and you can't tell me
how to vote because of the color of my
skin he's addressing
this ridiculous irony that you hear from
biden and the democrats which is
democracy is on the ballot and there's
only one choice
well if there's only one choice doesn't
sound an awful lot like democracy to me
they talk a good game on
democracy republican government but
really what they say is
regardless of what you want we're going
to tell you how to run your lives for
you
and we're going to insult you and we're
going to even insult your identity
if you don't get in line and do exactly
what we say
he says wait a second the the freedom
the liberty to have to vote for you in
lockstep all the time
is not liberty and at a deeper level it
gets to something we've talked about now
for months
which is the difference between liberty
and license liberty
uh being the ability to do what one
ought to do
license being the the ability to do
whatever one pleases
what the left is saying to the rioters
and criminals
running all around wisconsin is
that the only way for you to be free the
only way for you to throw off the yoke
of your oppression
is to go out and commit a lot of crimes
and attack people and violate other
people's rights
that's the only way you can be free the
reality of course
is the opposite the only way that you
can be free
is if you follow the rules if you pay
attention to law and order
if you participate in the natural give
and take of republican self-government
this is what the left has been doing for
decades now
they want you to trade your exalted
political freedom the freedom to rule
yourself
the freedom to rule your own passions
for a cheap
license that will allow you to do some
naughty things that you shouldn't be
doing that's that's the trade they're
offering
and it's not worth it but you can see
how it would be tempting
that's the high level of it the low
level is the typical one which is
give up some of your freedom give up
some of your rights and we'll give you
some free stuff
but but it's broader than that it's not
just passing out welfare checks
it's it passing out a cultural license
to do all sorts of bad things but there
is a cost i think we should all know
especially as conservatives there is a
cost to everything in this life no such
thing as a free lunch
and and the cost to engaging in this
kind of
crazy license in the streets is to give
up your ability
for self-rule and then who comes in
the democrats come in and you could see
those people in wisconsin
they they realized it albeit too late
they were they were larping it was a
live-action role play of this
anti-police protest
and yet the minute somebody goes down
from a bullet what do you call the cops
call the police it's just like a little
kid
who says i hate my parents i'm running
away from home i don't need you
and then you know they're they're
outside for one hour and things start to
get a little cold and scary and what do
they do they run home they mommy mommy
i'm sorry
i'm sorry take me back that's what's
happening with the left right now and
you almost pity them
you pity them because they've been lied
to
the mainstream media the liberal
establishment has been lying to all of
us
that attorney general of kentucky is not
in chains
as he says to joe biden he is not in
chains but we
increasingly may be we may be and it's
not just on these racial issues
it does all relate to the 2020 election
but
look at kovid look at what's going on
with kovid so
right now if you go into new york if i
were to go into you know i'm a new
yorker i've a lot of friends and family
in new york i can't go visit because
when you go visit
you are supposed to quarantine for 14
days
what is that i can't go i can't go for
more than two or three days
so i i'd be in quarantine the whole time
this creates a real problem if you're
gonna go visit new york
well not everybody has to quarantine for
14 days you see if you are a special
person
if you're a celebrity if you're someone
the democratic
rulers there like then you don't have to
quarantine
there is going to be the mtv video music
awards there
which i forgot existed but i guess
they're still going on
the mtv vmas are going to be in new york
a lot of people are gonna have to fly in
for it they will not be required to
quarantine themselves for 14 days you
see
regular old people who come in uh will
have to do so we'll have to quarantine
they could face a ten thousand dollar
fine and 15 days behind bars if they
don't do it
but the privileged group of hollywood
celebrities don't need to worry about
that
and actually i'm with the democratic
rulers there on their guidance for the
celebrities
what i'm against is the double standard
but what the double standard shows
again is this is not about public health
this
is about an election this is creating an
environment of fear
this is about keeping the country
continue to be locked down
this is about having political symbols
everywhere like the masks and the masks
have become
a political symbol joe biden made that
abundantly clear at the dnc
this is about spreading a an
environment a culture of fear
so what's it based on is it based on the
science capital s with the trademark
over the e
that's what fomo and all the other
democratic rulers told us it was
but it's not because if you look at our
public health department the cdc
they have now removed the guidelines
asking states to quarantine for any
period of time
as people come in this was on friday
the cdc removed language in the travel
guidelines
that suggested the 14-day quarantine
they didn't make a big announcement
about it they don't seem to make a big
announcement about any of these things
but they they did remove that language
so have the states followed suit and
removed their quarantines
no because once again this is not about
science or medicine or health
this is about politics
public health in general the cdc right
is this
this odd thing the left right now wants
to tell us it's all about health
but public health means it's not just
about health it's about politics public
and politics are synonymous here right
public and political so it's this it's
this weird
category where it's a blend of science
and politics
and the politics has fully taken over if
it hadn't already
why because of the election why are
other countries not doing what we're
doing
because of the election why do other
countries not have
murders going on in the streets right
now in civilized places because of the
election
why is the shooting concentrated in
wisconsin right now because of the
election
this is only going to get worse i say
this as i sign off every day
it's my uh i don't know if you'd call it
optimism or pessimism
because i i'm either saying i guess a
pessimist would say things can't get any
worse and i'm saying no they can and
they will
they're going to get worse until
november 3rd
but don't kid yourself and pretend it's
about the sun you got to be able to see
through that
science of public health to the public
and political aspect of it
they're already admitting if on
election day they they don't come out
with the presidency
they're already admitting that they're
not going to give up power
al gore saint al the savior of the world
the patron of of penguins and polar
bears
al gore came out and said that if joe
biden wins and trump won't give up power
he's kind of playing through this this
fantasy war game
then the military are going to see his
control and then we'll have a coup
d'etat
and then the permanent government the
bureaucracy the deep state
they will hand power to the good people
and he whips himself up
into a for him wonderful fantasy
it's important to say that it's really
not up to him
and i hear people saying well will he
accept the decision
well it doesn't matter it's not up to
him
because at noon on january 20th
if a new president is elected i i hope
joe biden is elected and if that
is the case uh the uh the
uh police force uh the secret service uh
the military all of the executive branch
officers will respond to the
command and direction of the new
president uh and so it
it will not matter uh whether donald
trump accepts it personally or not
this is a wonderful fantasy this is a
wonderful thing to daydream about if
you're a democrat because the democrats
hate having democratic elections
they hate that they have to go to the
people because sometimes those
deplorable irredeemable people
pick the wrong candidate and don't
forget there is a right candidate
according to the science of history it's
supposed to be the left-wing candidate
who wins
that's how you get progress we all know
that other than the rubes and the
villains
so it would just be so much better if we
could do away with this whole election
and
we just know it's the it's going to be
the democratic candidate who's supposed
to win and if the people won't accept
that then the military will come in and
stage a coup d'etat
but we'll we'll have good government in
the end won't that be wonderful and at
least
to al gore's credit he is promising all
of this
and joe biden's actually winning the
election right he says if biden is
elected but trump won't give up power
then
this is that and the other thing some
democrats won't even go that far
you know al gore himself refused to
concede the election that he lost
in 2000 when he was running for
president he wouldn't leave
his vice presidential residence finally
though
he did he finally relented well
other democratic politicians are not so
nice hillary clinton
has come out straight ahead and said
that under no circumstances should joe
biden
concede the election joe biden should
not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is gonna drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch and if we are as focused and
relentless
as the other side is as the other side
is i don't hear the other
side saying that donald trump should not
concede the election
under any circumstances hillary clinton
famously called for some of the violence
we're seeing around here when she said
it was a year
or two years ago she said that you can't
be civil with people who disagree with
you
can't be civil what are you gonna be
you're gonna be violent
we will get to what uh the former future
president means by all of that and one
second first i gotta thank you
uh our youtube channel here at the
michael and all shows just crossed 190
000 subscribers that is great we
appreciate it ring the bell get some
get some notifications on the page also
we're gonna have a backstage this friday
where we will be decompressing over the
rnc and we're gonna have an all-access
watch party starting tonight
at 8 15 eastern 5 15 pacific matt walsh
will be live streaming the entire night
of rnc speakers
and watching with you taking your
comments and questions letting you know
what he thinks as well i think matt
always does that i don't know of any
time
when matt has told you or when matt has
refrained from telling you what he
thinks
i will be hosting more live watch
parties every day for the rest of the
week don't miss out
i will be joining you tomorrow i'm very
excited to capture the last night of
this
excellent convention head on over to
dailywire.com
knowles you get 20 off all access and
two leftist years tumblers with
the coupon code access dailywire.com
knowles with coupon code access
to get 20 off your membership we'll be
right back with a lot more
hillary says joe biden should not
concede under
any circumstances and here you see
hillary clinton
whether because she's more intelligent
than al gore or she's more in the know
than
al gore or she just so doesn't give a
damn anymore
after the american people rejected her
that she's willing to put her cards on
the table
but what she's showing you is the
democratic strategy and it's why
the democrats are pushing so hard for
universal nationwide mail-in ballots
even when the public health
professionals
say there's no reason to have all these
mail-in ballots people can safely go to
the polls
why because it gives the democrats an
excuse
not to concede the election under any
circumstances
because we're not going to know on
election night we're not going to know
the winner it's not possible to know the
winner now
you have an expected 80 to 100 million
people voting
by mail-in ballot we know that people
are not going to hit the deadline but
their votes are going to be counted
or they're if they're democratic votes
they're going to be counted two or three
times probably
so it's gonna drag on how long four days
a week two weeks we don't know yet
but we know it's going to drag on we
know that the administrative government
is on the side of
democrats we know democrats are much
better at stealing elections at the
ballot box than republicans we've got a
lot of examples
in recent days we know that we have
ballot security
at polling places for this reason but
once you take the polling place out of
it it's much
more liable to be a corrupted election
and that's exactly what hillary wants
because the deplorable irredeemable
american people were not supposed to
have a say
they were not supposed to elect donald
trump
and so what does she do the guy gets
elected the guy beats her
she spends four years saying he's a
manchurian candidate for russia she's
still prattling on about the russia
thing
even though we had huge investigations
into this nothing
nothing came up totally debunked it was
a hoax
doesn't matter it's not that hillary
wants to lie all the time it's that
hillary doesn't care about the truth
and so they're going to continue to
stoke this violence they're going to
they're going to encourage violence
after the election i'm sure
and it's going to place us in a
situation where battleground states
the idea that politics is is the
civilized version of trying to attain
your ends in war well
we might be moving into more of a
territory where battleground states
really are battlegrounds
where war is the continuation of
politics by other means
you saw this happening in the 1850s
in the run-up to the civil war i'm not
saying we have to enter into a civil war
i hope we don't
but you're seeing a lot of the same
ingredients here the parallels
are a little bit eerie and the democrats
who are encouraging it who encouraged it
last time by the way
should should pull it back try to
preserve
civil society i think a lot of people
are noticing this even some lifelong
democrats
you know a lifelong democrat called into
c-span the other day
and he said i can't believe it but i'm
about to start voting
for republicans and it was because of
the difference at these conventions
not even just on the political front not
even just on the cultural front but all
the way down
to that theological conflict take a
listen
i'm a lifelong democrat i'm from la reno
ohio which is a democrat city in ohio
and i just want to say after watching
the convention tonight
on tv on c-span here i am definitely
changing my vote to republican and i'll
tell you what
they just put the democratic party they
started republican party to shame
i'm going to follow the republican party
now but why
what what what was it that convinced you
about tonight
it was the heartfelt way they came
across to the american people
and i was really touched by the number
of times they used
the word god they put god into
everything
and the people on the democratic side on
their convention act like they were
pushing god right out of it
and that had a lot to do with changing
my mind
the democrats of course were pushing god
right out of it they opened the muslim
caucus of the dnc
by removing the phrase under god from
the pledge of allegiance and they opened
the lgbt lmnop
caucus of the dnc in exactly the same
way they took
out the phrase under god and this really
mattered and i know that they're going
to be a lot of
democrats and a lot of squishy
republicans who roll their eyes at this
say oh my god you're going to you're
going to change your vote
you're going to change your vote which
could affect really important things
like marginal tax rates
because of some frivolous ridiculous
phrase like under god
oh how unsophisticated what rube what
rubes you must be you must be a bitter
clinger
like obama would call you and what those
very
fancy sophisticated people don't realize
is that that guy calling into c-span
understands more about politics than any
of them do
for many years the gop
said let's avoid those touchy cultural
issues let's avoid
redefining marriage let's avoid abortion
let's avoid immigration
let's avoid assimilation let's avoid
free trade let's avoid all of this it's
it's a little too touchy
let's just let's just push for people to
have a lot of stuff
and let's just talk about making
everybody rich and not talk about any of
the cultural issues that matter
certainly can't talk about religion
right and those republicans
lost they lost and lost and lost and
even when they won they lost because
they got nothing accomplished
and then that guy that bitter clinger
that guy who's a democrat
realizes that there's actually a
spiritual battle going on as well
it's why you know i spoke a few days ago
about the q
theory and some of the other kind of
more eccentric theories that are there
on the right
and i feel as though i irritated
everybody in my take on it which which i
always strive to do on the show as you
know i always try to irritate everybody
but because my take on it i didn't talk
about the specifics of the q theory
and whether or not this specific thing
is true or that specific thing is true
is i i don't really care about that as
much as i care about what it means
broader politically and the fact is this
the queue theory and other kinds of more
eccentric
uh movements and theories that have
cropped up on the internet
they they talk about politics in
explicitly
spiritual terms and that's all i care
about
i don't care about the rest of the
theory the fact that
that these kinds of theories that crop
up understand correctly
that politics has an ultimately
spiritual dimension
is all i need to know that this is a
natural
outgrowth of a politics that has long
denied that
that's natural and and frankly a
recognition that politics
has a spiritual basis should be
encouraged
people who recognize that recognize a
lot more about politics
than the eggheads do the power hungry
technocrats
who want to run your lives for you
it's an important element you know one
one issue that republicans don't want to
touch is the transgender issue
oh it's too touchy it's too complicated
i can't get into it
well a few people have some cojones
including doug lamalfa
who is a congressman from california who
just
put out the protecting children from
experimentation act
don't trans the kids you could call it
this would prohibit doctors
from performing the experimental gender
reassignment treatments on children
obviously you can't reassign your gender
but you can castrate children and pump
them full of hormones and
and completely ruin their biology you
can do that and that's probably not a
good thing to do
to children puberty blocking hormones
followed by cross-sex hormones that
cause irreversible damage
to children's bodies including permanent
sterilization
including an increased risk of cancer
including all sorts of terrible things
this congressman came out there and said
no we can't do that anymore
the way republicans are going to win is
not by following
the squishy method of ignoring all the
issues that actually matter in just
trying to give people tax cuts
tax cuts are good too but it has to be
in addition to
taking on head-on these tough cultural
issues
the reason republicans don't want to
take on these tough cultural issues is
because democrats get violent and they
encourage violence
and they they get vicious when you do
that sort of thing look at what's
happening in wisconsin
now all because of the election
that's not a reason to pull back in fact
that's evidence
that when we talk about these cultural
issues we're right over the target we're
doing
exactly what we should be doing because
democrats aren't threatened by low taxes
they can always just raise the taxes
again
what they're threatened by is changing
the cultural perceptions in the country
or by giving voice to the cultural
positions that already exist
and by veering off the course of
progress with a capital p
that involves massive racial division
taking away our cherished legal
and political tradition toppling george
washington
and pumping children full of hormones
that will
castrate them that's progress if that's
progress
i'm not interested in progress i want
whatever the opposite of progress
is and there's evidence that this is
working
just look at the numbers from the two
conventions we had the dnc last week we
had the rnc this week
according to the hill c-span's live
stream of the rnc
gathered 440 000 views on the internet
it doesn't seem like a lot obviously
there are other streaming platforms
but the dnc by comparison only got 76
000 views
the rnc got six times the digital views
according to the hill
as the dnc 16 you wouldn't know that
from the media if you just watch the
mainstream media you'd say
man people are really sick of trump and
they really hate these republicans and
no one's going to be watching
and the democrats we have all these
famous celebrities and really
really polished presentation here and
the republicans they're just kind of
giving speeches and it's a bunch of
members of the trump family and it's
that's no one wants to see that well
actually many many more people do want
to see that
why is it because they they happen to
really like the trump family
including all of the relatives and the
children i don't think that's why i
don't think they dislike them but i
don't think it's
it's just because of personality i think
it's because of what they're doing you
know
ann coulter when she wrote that book
with the hilarious title but it was
actually a very good book
called e-pluribus awesome in trump we
trust
but all of ann's books have great titles
the the argument in the book was that
everyone thinks that trump got elected
because of his personality in spite of
his policies
but actually the opposite is true he got
elected he got elected in spite of his
personality
because of his policies because he
actually offered different policies
than any of the other republicans on
stage and different policies than any of
the democrats
he was offering voice to the forgotten
men and women of this country
to use the campaign's phrase that's what
this is about it's
actually gets back to that youtube
question we talked about at the top is
this about a state of being or are you
racist or are you anti-racist are you
not racist
is it about just you you your
personality
or is it about things you're doing
concretely specifically
concrete examples like tim scott gave
which isn't
i think people like the concrete reality
i don't think we like the fantasy
i think we're waking up like those
larpers in wisconsin
who have been indulging this ideological
fantasy for so long
we forgot that as is the conservative
consolation reality reasserts itself in
the end
and halfway through when our when our
anti-police protest gets a little too
rowdy
and reality creeps through all of the
ridiculous rhetoric what do we say
call the cops call the cops
call the police give me law and order
i'm sorry i didn't mean it when i was
tearing down george washington
when i was tearing down thomas jefferson
when i was burning the flag and tearing
down my country
i didn't know what i was doing i just
got a little carried away i had been
whipped
up into a frenzy by the mainstream media
and by the democratic party and by big
technology
and by the administrative government and
by higher education and by lower
education
by the entire liberal established
apparatus
which convinced me of a lie and a
fantasy
that i don't really like anymore now
that i see
what the reality of that is call the
cops
do we want our battleground states to
continue to descend into actual
battlegrounds
and the politics of self-government
whereby we persuade
one another we have public debate and we
vote and we accept the results of those
elections
do we want that do we you know the old
system the thing we're tearing down
or do we want all that bare-knuckle
brawling more than bare-knuckles
brawling with weapons shooting each
other actual battlegrounds the complete
collapse of civil society and civil
government which do you want
that is a choice in the election it's
not in a sense democracy
is on the ballot not the way that joe
biden means it but that is the choice
in how we're going to conduct ourselves
what what country do we want even the
people who think that orange man very
very bad
do you want to continue to indulge this
fantasy at our own peril even as the
bullets
that are flying are real or do we want
to
pull back from that wake up
tune out that fantasy and take back our
government and our politics
for ourselves and for self-rule that's
the choice
it's all about the election i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll
give it a listen